you see investors clearly reacting to
this so some certainly some nervousness
out there
surrounding not just what we saw unfold
with the Malaysia airline flight but now
Israel beginning this ground invasion
into Gaza what is what does that mean
for the region and concerns that we have
here back here at home well I mean it's
hard to imagine a more combustive
ingredients than what just happened in
the Ukraine combined with Israeli
invasion today and then the backdrop of
what's going on in Iraq with Isis but if
you step back and look at what just
happened with the surface-to-air missile
incident potentially one one of the
important implications here is that it's
not known yet and we need to be cautious
about whether if in fact that happened
but I can tell you from my time in the
CIA where we armed the Mujahideen with
Stinger missiles to fight the Russians
and we were very concerned about what
happens if those missiles got into the
wrong hands and we're used against
commercial aircraft when I was at
Homeland Security we were again worried
about that post 9/11 and most recently
in Libya when Qaddafi fell we were very
concerned about getting our hands on the
surface-to-air missiles they had so it
was your fear here that the Russians
actually provided the separatists with
this weaponry it's it's possible we've
used we've done the same thing against
the Russians in other context ie
Afghanistan and so again I have no
conclusive evidence of that and we need
to be very cautious on that front but
the point is at a time of heightened
tensions around the world it is it's a
scenario that we were always fearing is
that these surface-to-air missiles would
be used against civilian aircraft and
unfortunately it's one of those
scenarios liberally I mean you know you
worry about everything do you worry in
this particular case that this may have
been a deliberate move well I think in
this cat's what's unfortunate once you
release the genie out of the bottle you
can't control it and I think in the case
of the Russians I do not believe that it
makes sense for them it's not in their
self-interest nor is it and they and the
rebels interest if shot down a civilian
aircraft so the reality is they probably
did not intend to hit a civilian
aircraft they thought they were
targeting a military asset but the key
point is again these weapons are
extremely dangerous and once you let
them the genie out of the bottle you
can't control it anymore so that
something will have to continue to watch
and I can guarantee you they'll be
issues raised in the US Congress and
elsewhere about whether we should
consider other countermeasures put on
commercial aircraft to address this
threat vector let me ask you about
Israel and Gaza we are getting reports
and I should clarify reports saying that
the ground invasion may have started in
over the last couple of days there's
been a thinking that this is pretty much
inevitable that there's really not an
easy peaceful resolution in front of us
right now to the situation that's
unfolding there how do you see this
escalating as we as we do seem to be
getting word that Israel may have begun
this ground invasion well I think two
points one is if you look at the attempt
to have a peaceful settlement
obviously when Egypt and and Israel I
thought they were entering into a
ceasefire agreement they didn't have all
parties on board so what's gonna have to
happen now is enough pain and threshold
has to be reached to get the parties
back to the table
the Hamas and the Palestinians others
have on their side the pain threshold is
is that they're missiles so going back
to the missile theme of the day the
problem they have is that the Israeli
counter missile defense system the Iron
Dome is so effective that it will be
very difficult for Hamas to be able to
counter the Israelis with any kind of
pressure until the Israel finishes its
operation
so again missiles are one of the themes
of the day and I think the more we can
talk about how those are being used both
in Syria and the new cane Ukraine
context as well as here it's very
relevant
definitely just back to Segway back to
the markets as we watch sit down now off
131 points S&P down 1% 21 points Jason
how much do you think is in fact a
tribute able to the conflict that we're
seeing unfold today well I think it's
part of a broader tableau I think as
Chad mentioned because you've had a
number of things that have happened and
I would say even domestically to that
would suggest that perhaps there's a
situation a vacuum of power around the
world so here in the United States you
also have the situation on our southern
border you also have corporate tax
inversions which suggest that there's
not the power at the federal government
that perhaps there should be and then
you have what might seem to be a lack of
American power projection of American
power abroad but you're seeing in Iraq
and you're seeing perhaps in the Ukraine
and those are sort of some political
issues here but when you look at the
concerns that seem to be reflected right
now in the market and the market sort of
an indicator of what's going to happen
in the future it's not necessarily
reflecting stability given what we just
saw today unfold there in eastern
Ukraine and now it looks like in Gaza
well your point earlier about VIX being
what is it now yeah almost 32 percent
today I mean highest level we've seen
since January so to Jason's point I
think that that not so much desolate a
political issue but if you look at from
a rational economic point of view the
instability there is going to have a
meaningful impact on a variety of fronts
we just think about on the oil parameter
alone at the gas pump we're already
seeing a very substantial increase that
was starting just with Iraq and now
spilling over the tensions in Israel are
only going to add fuel to that fire
you know and again it does seem that
we're looking at the VIX now just over
fourteen over fourteen up 32 percent the
S&P now sitting at lows of the session
when you look at what is happening right
now and let's let's just look at Israel
and Gaza is there some kind of
resolution that we can have a role in
what should the u.s. be doing or is this
now still their issue their problem can
we affect this in a positive way Jack
there's definitely the US has levers of
influence no question about it but
ultimately that the decision to
ceasefire will be obviously the and I do
want to confirm sorry to interrupt sorry
Bloomberg News has learned from the
Israeli prime minister's office that in
fact the ground operation in Gaza has
started so again we had been getting
reports of some heavy artillery fire
being heard we are confirming through
the Israeli prime minister's office that
the ground operation in Gaza has started
but please resume so I think Trish on
that front the operation you know likely
will be done at Israel's discretion and
ended at Israel's discretion but going
back to your question about does the
u.s. have an opportunity influence
there's no question that the number one
foreign aid provider to Israel is the
United States they will do what they
have to do to defend themselves but at
some point given the relative asymmetric
strength in Israel to those in Gaza and
we talked about before the Iron Dome
providing Israel with relative
indiscretion to move offensively
ultimately we will be able to ask Israel
to show some restraint and bring the
parties back to the table but as Jason
said earlier I think the key question is
whether how much investment is the
United States willing to make and
arguably right now that's one of the
regions where they can we can't have and
do have significant leverage you know
what is the risk for Israel going in
with a ground invasion the bottom line
is militarily there's there's obviously
some minimal risk of life but if you
look at again the asymmetric superiority
of the Israeli military it's relatively
low risk for them the
bigger issue is the could this spark for
example a broader reaction from the Arab
community that surrounds Israel you know
this could absolutely be used as a rally
cry in Syria in Iraq to take arms up
against Israel in a variety of ways so
stay tuned the spillover effect is
likely to be meaningful